parte de encuentra las coordenadas de
todos los puntos en la curva en los
cuales la recta tangente de la curva sea
vertical entonces queremos encontrar los
puntos en la curva cuya recta tangente
sea vertical así que recordemos un poco
qué significa tener una recta tangente
vertical como su pendiente bueno
empecemos por una recta horizontal si tú
tienes una recta horizontal como ésta
que tengo aquí entonces podemos decir
que su pendiente es cero otra forma de
pensarlo es decir que la derivada de
james con respecto a x de esta recta
horizontal es 0 muy bien y ahora qué
pasa con una recta vertical supongamos
que esta es mi recta vertical bueno si
tienes una recta vertical como ésta cuál
es la tasa de cambio del yen con
respecto a x
cuál es su pendiente bueno algunas
personas podrían decir que en este caso
la derivada de con respecto a x es decir
su pendiente es infinito o también
puedes decir que es indefinida
d
fin
'vida y bueno cualquiera de estos dos
razonamientos es correcto porque en
algún punto estaríamos dividiendo entre
0 tienes un gran cambio en james y
ningún cambio en x ahora también hay
otra forma de pensar esto mismo y esta
forma nos ayudará a resolver este
problema si decimos cuánto vale la
derivada de x con respecto ayer es decir
observa que me estoy tomando el
recíproco ahora tengo la derivada de x
con respecto ayer y en este caso
esto sería igual a 0 porque tu tiempo
cambia mucho pero tu x no cambia
entonces podemos tener esta idea de aquí
en esto para una recta vertical y pensar
en las coordenadas de todos los puntos
en la curva en los cuales la recta
tangente de la curva sea vertical y lo
bueno es que acá arriba nos dan ya cuál
es la derivada de que con respecto a x
eso es muy importante así que déjame
anotarlo de nuevo la derivada de james
con respecto a x nos dice en el problema
es lo mismo que bueno bien esto sobre
tres veces de cuadrada menos x muy bien
entonces una cosa que podemos hacer es
ver cuando la derivada de x con respecto
a james es igual a cero y aquí tenemos
la derivada de con respecto a x así que
si nos tomamos el recíproco nos quedaría
la derivada de x con respecto a alguien
que es justo lo que queremos y bueno
para esto habrá que tomarnos el
recíproco de este que va a ser lo mismo
que 3
cuadrada - x esto a su vez dividido
entre 10 y bueno lo que quiero hacer es
que esto sea igual a 0 es justo lo que
me dice aquí y si queremos que esto sea
igual a cero entonces tenemos que
igualar a cero la parte de arriba el
numerador esto que tengo aquí tiene que
ser igual a cero entonces déjame bajar
un poco esta pantalla para ver para qué
x y para qué y en tres y cuadrada menos
x es igual a cero
queremos que 3 bien cuadrada menos x
esto sea igual a 0 y bueno esto va a ser
igual a 0 cuando 3 y cuadrada sea igual
a x lo único que hice fue sumar x de
ambos lados
ahora otra forma de pensarlo es decir
para qué valor x james la derivada de 10
con respecto a x es indefinida y bueno
es indefinida si el denominador esta
parte de acá abajo es igual a 0 y
observa que estaríamos llegando justo a
lo mismo y bueno es que al final cuando
hablamos de cosas indefinidas pensamos
en cosas no tan intuitivas en cosas
confusas pero si pensamos en la tasa de
cambios de x con respecto a james y
pensamos que esto sea igual a cero yo
creo que eso nos lleva a la misma
conclusión y me parece que es más
intuitivo bueno entonces buscamos todas
las xy que cumplan que tres ya cuadrada
sea igual a equis pero que además estén
en la curva es decir que también
satisfagan esta ecuación que tenemos acá
arriba y elevado al cubo menos x james
es igual a 2 es más déjeme anotarlo acá
abajo también queremos que vivan en la
curva y la curva tiene como ecuación
kubica - x bien esto tiene que ser igual
a 2 entonces por qué no usamos estas dos
ecuaciones e intentamos resolver para x
y para allá y lo que más fácilmente se
me ocurre es que sustituyamos a x que
sabemos que vale 3 y cuadrada justo aquí
en esta ecuación justo aquí la tenemos
entonces si tomo la ecuación original de
la curva tendría que kubica menos y aquí
tengo x james pero buscamos una x que
sea igual a 3 de cuadrada así que lo voy
a poner aquí que multiplica a 310
cuadrada y esto a su vez que multiplica
y que sea igual a 2 y observa que de
aquí ya podemos obtener el valor del yen
porque entonces tengo que kubica menos
a veces se ubican esto tiene que ser
igual a dos o dicho otra manera menos
dos veces
jake ubican esto tiene que ser igual a 2
y cierra divido de ambos lados entre
menos 2 de ambos lados entre menos 2 voy
a obtener que jett kubica tiene que ser
igual a menos 1 o lo que es lo mismo
bien tiene que ser igual a menos 1
porque menos 1 elevado al cubo es lo
mismo que menos 1 y bueno sí ahora ya
tenemos que ya tiene que tomar el valor
de menos 1 para que se cumplan estas dos
ecuaciones simultáneamente ahora cuánto
vale x
bueno pues x es igual a tres veces
cuadrada pero ya tenemos el valor de
james es menos 1 entonces me va a quedar
3 x menos 1 elevado al cuadrado y menos
un elevado al cuadrado es lo mismo que
uno entonces me va a quedar que x toma
el valor de 3
y ya está porque si nos preguntan las
coordenadas de todos los puntos en la
curva en los cuales la recta tangente a
la curva sea vertical bueno ya tenemos
que el punto tres coma menos uno este va
a ser el punto en la curva en el cual la
recta tangente a la curva es vertical y
ya con esto tenemos nuestra respuesta y
hemos acabado